en annonçant une restriction sur les
voyageurs européens dans notre homme a
asséné un véritable coup aux compagnies
aériennes
on en parle avec mehran ebrahimi
professeur titulaire au département
management technologies de l'école des
sciences de gestion de l'uqam qui est
toujours en californie depuis plusieurs
mois d'ailleurs bonsoir mélanie brahimi
il vous sort
quel est l'impact d'une telle décision
celle du président sur les compagnies
aériennes
écoutez ça je pense que monsieur trope
avec cette déclaration la vienne semer
la zizanie partout dans la vie dans la
vie quotidienne des américains et ça je
peux en témoigner
mais également au niveau des compagnies
aériennes parce que là tout d'un coup on
est en train de si vous voulez porter un
coup énorme à l'ag d'hier est la
légitimité à la dimension sécurité mais
pas dans le sens technique dans le sens
sécurité en vol c'est à dire de ce qu'on
attrape la maladie au parle on a
transformé avec cette déclaration la
voyager en avion comme quelque chose de
dangereux pour la santé
et ça je pense que sa compagnie avait
bien sûr des premiers à être touché par
ça est ce que on voit des images de
lufthansa ou d'air france ou d'air
canada
est ce que le risque n'est pas vraiment
pour ses grandes entreprises mais
davantage pour les petites compagnies
aériennes tout à fait il faut savoir que
un bon nombre de compagnies des petites
compagnies mais aussi des compagnies ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui de la low cost
sont des compagnies qui sont vraiment à
la marge
tout al'air tout proche de la ligne de
rentabilité juste en 2019 ya 23
compagnies low cost qui ont fait
faillite parce que le prix de pétrole a
augmenté de quelques cents
alors vous imaginez aujourd'hui avec la
réduction et parle d air transat mais on
n'a vu personne la semaine dernière la
faille de flybe qui quand une compagnie
s'est accompagnée important donc avec la
diminution donc des réservations donc
c'est moins de revenus ce qui fait en
sorte que ça va être considérable la
perte pour ces compagnies là la seule
chose qui vient peut-être qu'ils games
qui peut amortir ce choc là c'est la
diminution considérable du prix pétrole
donc ce qui fait que le coût de kérosène
aujourd'hui c'est moi et donc dans les
estimations qu'on fait peut-être
aujourd'hui les cours fixe au moins
élevés mais dans l'autre côté les avions
volent ou alors il coûte moins cher à
voler mais bonne part donc ce qui fait
que les os
l'absence des revenus sont très
importants et il est évident que des
compagnies par exemple prendre le cas
d'une origine qui était déjà en déficit
qui est misait beaucoup son sens en
déploiement par exemple au niveau de la
poste
outre atlantique la donc tous ses vols à
sont aujourd'hui annulée donc ces gens
ces compagnies là si la crise perdure un
petit peu ils ne seront certainement pas
est ce que cette interdiction imposée
par le président des états unis pourrait
chambouler l'ensemble de l'industrie du
tourisme
oui tout à fait parce que encore une
fois très souvent alors malgré le
mouvement on l avion et tout ça
n'empêche quand même que l'avion c'était
un élément essentiel important pour le
tourisme pour tous le disent tout tout
certain que ça soit ici à l'intérieur
des états unis que ce soit intra
continentale ou internationale doc
l'avion et je dirais le véhicule par
excellence donc à partir du moment où on
fait donc deux dames vols un élément de
risque et en plus vous allez vers un
pays par exemple vous partez du canada
des états-unis de l'europe où il ya un
système de santé on va dire acceptable
et solide
si vous allez vers des destinations
touristiques où il fait bon désolé mais
on n'est pas nécessairement donc en
présence le système de santé très très
avec lui nos standards allons donc ce
qui fait que les gens hésitent les gens
ont peur donc ils ont peur de prendre
l'avion en ayant peur d'attraper la
maladie et de nous de l'autre côté
donc ils m'ont dans des territoires où
le système de santé lors et inconnues
donc ce qui fait que tout ça est cumulé
sais c'est ça fait ça fait peur et ceux
qui aujourd'hui étrange c'est que les
vols intérieurs américains aussi était
très très touché
monsieur trempage mais d'une espèce de
jeu les dires démagogie comme il a
l'habitude en pointant les avions il
faut quand même se dire que le système
d'aération d'un avion est aussi précis
qu'un système d'aération de salles
d'opération à l'hôpital autrement dit
l'air de la bio et et filtrer toutes les
deux trois minutes donc c'est un air
sain sur le contact direct avec les si
vous voulez avec les liquides donc
d'accord mais sinon il vient de semer la
zizanie et donc les vols les
réservations nouvelle maladie aux
etats-unis ont chuté considérablement
vous êtes installé en californie pour le
travail depuis plusieurs mois comment
perçois temps la décision chez vous
depuis hier de ce qui se passe alors la
première chose c'est que on la vit
pratiquement tout de suite après lalanne
ans les gens ont commencé à aller vers
les supermarchés
mais ce matin je le vis moi même donc
les supermarchés qu'on fréquente et
jusqu'à hier que façon très normale
ordinaire donc il ya assez de choses là
tout d'un coup les gens sont arrivés ils
ont vidé les supermarchés donc il ya eu
on disait dans un radio radio locale je
l'ait pas vu moi même il y avait deux
heures de queue pour pouvoir entrer dans
un course qu donc voyez ce qui était
normal car entière est devenu très très
peu une panique générale mais ce qui est
étrange et je pense que monsieur propre
a les raisons de faire cette cette
déclaration là parce que il a non
seulement mobiliser sa base électorale
mais il est allé chercher d'autres
personnes par exemple ce matin c'était à
une réunion à l'université et des gens
qui ne sont pas du tout les partisans de
monsieur traduisons même de 18° des
autocollants de benue certes elles sont
là en voiture
ces gens là est satisfait de cette
déclaration de 30 parce que pour
l'américain moyen
le fait que les européens ne puissent
pas venir aux états unis ça les dérange
pas par contre ça passe comme une mesure
je dirais une ferme de la part du
président pour protéger les américains
donc il a vraiment fait un mort
politique assez intéressant maintenant
qui peut pas avoir des meetings
politiques ça je pense qu'il ya partie
relativement important des américains
qui sont en faveur de sa décision
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup mais rennais brahimi des
propos très intéressant ce soir merci
c'est toujours un plaisir ce qu'il y
aura bientôt
au retour dans la tourmente des
changements majeurs à la tête de
bombardier et d'hydro-québec
alain bellemare qui de bombardier éric
martel s'en va chez bombardier
ce soir une émission spéciale question
de coronavirus quels sont vos
inquiétudes vos interrogations
entre mythe et réalité nos experts vous
donne l'heure juste
24 60 ce soir 19h ici a dit mam il
arrive la confiance est essentielle pour
bien se diriger pour se sentir en
sécurité on savoir sur qui compter pour
vous entendre il s'est redit avec